hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about online language tutors and
how to get the most out of them again if
if you enjoyed this video please give it
a like and if you enjoy my channel don't
hesitate to subscribe because my goal
here is to talk about language learning
share some of my experience in learning
I'm working on my 21st language I guess
I only really speak 10 or 11 of them you
know in the sense that I can just start
speaking now but whatever I have
invested in these other languages it's
still there and I'm gonna go back to
them right now I'm working on 3
languages
I started Arabic then Farsi and now
Turkish and I'm gonna go back to them
again and again and hopefully bring them
all along because I'm I'm using these
languages to explore that part of the
world a part of the world that I don't
know very much about now this morning I
had an online session with my Turkish
tutor it's my third online session in
Turkish so I want to share with you with
you some of my views about online
language discussions how to use them
what I get out of them and also how my
views have changed I used to wait six
months eight months before talking to a
tutor I don't remember how long I waited
with Russian but I think was a long time
for the longest time I just listened to
my Russian or read my Russian you know
audiobooks Tolstoy ekam SP whatever it
might be and I never spoke with Czech
which was the next Slovak language we're
really it's a you know 60% identifiably
the same vocabulary essentially the same
grammatical structure easier to read
because it's written in the Latin
alphabet but again I waited six months
before I started speaking in fact I
thought I remember saying to yard who
was my tutor that you know I'm starting
earlier than I have and I struggled and
now I am I started five weeks in the
Turkish speaking so what's changed well
I think the availability of good sort of
past beginner or even the fact that I
begin right into the many stories with
all of the repetition and I'm finding to
that in Turkish adlink we actually have
a lot of sort of that next level kind of
material natural conversations that are
transcribed so the availability of sort
of that call it that next level of
material the fact that you know link
works better than it used to the fact
that the many stories have a lot of
repetition all of that has helped me
start earlier but I also have a better
sense of what I want the tutor to do to
do so my interaction with the tutor is a
number of things it's first of all a
record of my progress in the language so
I will have these you know oh I should
step back choose a good tutor so if a
tutor doesn't give me a good report from
our discussion I find another one who
will I don't want a tutor who spends too
much time correcting me I want a tutor
that sends me at least two three minutes
worth of words and phrases that I
struggled with I don't necessarily have
to have everything corrected during our
conversation but I want to get a list of
at least some of the mistakes and some
of the areas where I had difficulty a
good tutor will record these words and
phrases so I can listen to them over and
over again so the combination of this
report and the audio then becomes a
lesson in link which I you know store
under this sort of conversation reports
course and I can go back six months from
now I can go back to one of these
conversation reports when I go to review
my Farsi my Persian or my Arabic I can
go back to some of these lessons that
I've had so in our discussions we try to
talk about things that I'm able to talk
about I also like it if the tutor speaks
a language that we have in common
usually English because I like to
explain what I expect of the tutor so
this tutor understands what I want that
I want to have a conversation as much as
possible I don't want overcorrection
and I want as as complete a list as
possible of the words and phrases that I
struggled with and if possible the audio
I will even stop the tutor I'll suggest
to the - look we can stop ten minutes
early so you can do up this report
typically they say no that's not
necessary
many of the online tutors are used to
this idea they develop a report in
Google Documents they recorded I mean
this is part of what's happening in
online language teaching so you know
this development of a sort of a collet
like a cottage industry of online tutors
either operating on their own or
operating through sites like I talked he
is a major part of what's happening to
online language learning so I'm happy I
was very the tutor head this morning was
the best one I've had and I'm just very
happy and I'm looking forward to more
engagement I typically will speak maybe
once twice maybe three times a week
because it is a full hour and then I
come away very motivated to go back to
my input activities so I will go over my
conversation report with the tutor
listening and reading but then I will
dive back into some of the you know
content that I've not discovered at link
because again I can follow on my feet
but other people are studying and I'll
go through there and see if there's
items that are at my level and and
interesting and there are some so I want
to get back at my conversation report
but then get back into those content
items were again a lot of the same
structures a lot of the same words and
phrases are going to be there for me and
all of this helps me gradually get used
to the structure so there you have it I
mean if I've been at you know if we talk
about three months you know we got these
90-day challenges I'm kind of halfway
through my first three months of Turkish
I definitely want to get back to Persian
before I lose too much of it so it's
gonna be a bit of a challenge going
forward balancing the Arabic the Persian
and the Turkish so that I don't slip too
badly before I go back in there so I
might intersperse some tutor sessions
with
my Persian and Arabic tears anyway I
just wanted to share that with you on
the subject of you know online language
teachers bye for now
you